j'ai j'ai 118 là dans quelques jours tu
religieuses parce que le bon Dieu m'a
voulu il m'a un bon billet
une façon parfaite
on sent qu'on se connait peut-être
c'était la guerre on a eu très peur de
l'avoir des mauvaises nouvelles j'avais
un frère qui malheureusement a été
blessé et un qui est revenu sain et sauf
et qui s'était engagé à 18 ans il a été
officier les gens étaient plus fier de
leur pays elles sont françaises mérité
la valeur de notre pays en disant revenu
j'avais
16 ans alors j'étais heureux comme tout
[Musique]
parce que le bon Dieu m'a voulu il m'a
il m'a un beau minet
d'une façon parfaite je ne trouvais pas
à aimer à fond j'ai fréquenté
chose religieuses et tout barbe
à un moment donné j'ai dit mais voilà ma
voix je vais être religieuse et ça
réussit moi j'ai aimé le bon Dieu
par-dessus tout et il m'a bien rendu
en place
pour les enfants jamais fait beaucoup
beaucoup mais petit me manque et vous
savez pas que j'ai retrouvé
le plus jeune qui a qui a 80 ans je
n'apprécie que personnellement moi
alors j'aime bien les gens qui
s'occupent des personnes âgées
sinon c'est zéro on se rend pas compte
de ce qu'elles ont fourni
que le bonheur qu'elles ont donné à leur
famille
[Musique]
oh non je veux pas gagner
je n'ai pas du tout envie mon désir
c'est de mourir et de
retrouver mon frère non non j'ai pas eu
peur d'abord je crois que je peux faire
confiance au bon Dieu je ne sais pas
s'il me fait confiance mais je sais qui
il tarda j'ai l'impression qu'il m'a
oublié je le lui dis toujours
[Musique]
chargée par je l'appréciais que les gens
je ne me mets pas du président de la
République en ce moment-là je m'occupe
plus les humains
je suis allé voir sa maison et sa femme
il était à sa fin il est mort quelques
jours après j'aime bien jusqu'en haut
[Musique]